[Music]
we had the beautiful Alice Eve on the
show last night he does a terrific job
in the movie and I guess you've been
taking some heat for a scene I didn't
personally see what the fuss was about
myself I was quite happy about the scene
but there's a scene where Alice Eve Kirk
gets a quick look at her in her
underwear she's changing and and the
idea was the the intent was it's Kirk
who was always there sort of womanizing
character yeah the idea was have a beat
like that in the midst of all this
action and adventure he takes a quick
peek
however he looks it doesn't look away I
don't think I quite ended the seat in
the right way but look she to me it was
a sort of balance there's a scene
earlier where he's not dressed either so
it felt like it was a sort of you know a
trade-off but some people did feel like
it was you know exploiting her and while
she is lovely I could also see their
point of view okay well there is I think
we should explore this more this is the
photo still of her in the scene very
beautiful and I you know and you have
defended this you can take it away
that's okay da rector one to keep
defending it but but then there's a the
kingdom picture of Kirk who's also and
there's a thing like he's a married
couple girls yeah so that's okay so that
had a scene this is this is true we had
a shot of the the villain played by
Benedict Cumberbatch we had a scene with
him where we saw him actually taking a
shower and I actually brought a piece of
the clip it didn't make it this did not
of the movie but we had this and this is
one of those things we ended up cutting
so we can show let's take a look at this
[Music]
he's not enjoying that shower very much
no hehe that was a shower of evil yeah a
shower of evil yeah you know I saw that
just seconds before the show and I
thought that would look better with
different music what do you mean this is
just well take a look I just wanted
[Music]
you know I I would have used it if we
had if we had that music you don't have
access to that guy true I have a budget
here that you could never dream up